vous avez votre smartphone à écran
pliable au lieu de se plier en deux
comme font tous les modèles qu'on a pu
voir actuellement il se plie en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous voilà à londres je suis sur le
départ j'ai passé deux jours hyper cool
pour parler d'éducation ça on en parlera
dans quelques jours probablement demain
probablement mais juste avant je vous
parle d'un truc qui est hallucinant je
sais pas si vous avez suivi on parle
beaucoup de smartphones à écran pliable
c'est vraiment des outils qui vont se
développer davantage
il y a un rôle qui était le premier à
sortir sa copie il y à samsung qui a
déjà présenté en catimini rapidement
lumières éteintes lors d'une
présentation il ya pas très longtemps
son smartphone à écran pliable on sait
que lenovo respect série dessus on sait
que wahiba soumissionner dessus et là
c'est au tour de chien omis de montrer
par le biais de son cofondateur et
président et linkedin
il a fait une vidéo qui a publié sur
weibo qui est un réseau social chinois
et ils montrent leur smartphone à écran
pliable alors c'est probablement encore
tout de suite un proto c'est pas un
produit qui est commercialisé dans
l'immédiat n'est moins sûr dans les
courses et il le montre ils le font
savoir avec un tout qui franchement
hallucinant alors l'idée vous avez votre
smartphone à écran pliable au lieu de se
plier en deux comme font tous les
modèles qu'on a pu voir actuellement il
se plie en 3 et l'idée c'est quoi c'est
que lorsqu'il est ouverte vous avez une
grande table est probablement avec une
diagonale de 8 pouces c'est un peu ce
qu'on retrouve chez rhodiole et chez
samsung
mais une fois pliée vous avez deux rabat
et vous retrouvez avec un smartphone
d'un format un peu plus standard alors
le truc qui franchement cool c'est de
voir comment on passe d'une énorme
tablette un smartphone un peu classique
le point un peu négatif c'est que
lorsqu'il est pliée à l'arrière l'écran
reste allumée du coup ça va être
forcément plus énergivores il faudra une
batterie un peu plus performant de
l'arrière en tout cas être vraiment
réussi une prouesse c'est le fait
d'avoir un smartphone avec des
tout-petits bord et une fois fermé il
est compact ça c'est cool parce que
lorsque vous regardez la copie de riols
jeu déprimant ya pas très longtemps
le résultat est pas hyper probants vous
avez un truc énorme vous avez gros jour
dessous le truc est pas terrible pour le
mettre dans la poche là par contre ce
café xiaomi c'est vraiment hyper hyper
intéressant même lorsque vous l'ouvrez
vous avez des petits bords tous les
côtés enfin le truc est franchement
vraiment pratique
et lorsqu'il est fermé luton dans votre
main comme vous avez l'écran qui va
piloter comme vous en tout cas le pli
l'écran il ya un côté un peu plus
immersif c'est vraiment intéressant
alors le tout va tourner forcément sur
me why 1 me why adapté à
justement smartphone pliable et tout ça
bien évidemment sur un android aussi
complètement adapté un écosystème pour
un smartphone pliable
[Musique]
du coup ce qu'on voit c'est que la prise
en main est franchement hyper agréable
lorsque bouteille dans une main il
informa de smartphone classique alors
pour l'instant on n'a pas vu s'il y
avait des caméras donc est ce qu'il y
aura un fail seul bloc escuraing comera
comment ça va se faire ça ça reste un
peu en suspens pour l'instant il n'ya
pas être particulièrement d'infos là
dessus il pas non plus de capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui peut être
positionné à l'arrière donc un capteur
d'empreinte digitale au dos pour le
virus a fait un petit peu compliqué à
moins intégré un capteur d'empreintes
digitales directement sous l'écran oled
pour coup ça pourrait aussi être
intéressant autre problématique c'est le
fait sur mon smartphone qui tombe autre
problématique c'est le fait de ne pas
pouvoir mettre deux coques de protection
donc il faut vraiment que le smartphone
soit hyper résistant lui-même que
l'écran ne risque pas de s'abîmer pas de
s'altérer on peut imaginer un film que
vous allez mettre sur le dessus qui va
se plier est-ce qu'il va tenir wind
enfin ça soulève plein de problématique
c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
bailin been le prendre le tourner et
qu'on voit que lorsqu'il est replié
il reste franchement hyper fin à peu
près dans des dimensions de ce qu'on
peut avoir aujourd'hui sur des
smartphones donc ça c'est franchement
cool et c'est à dire une vraie prouesse
technique une prouesse qu'a pas réussi à
faire royal alors brouillonne a vraiment
sorti un smartphone à écran pliable pour
être le premier à le faire pour faire un
buzz pour montrer et techno pas pour le
commercialiser le vent du grand public
néanmoins la copie cheo mis telle
qu'elle est là elle paraît franchement
séduisante et l'idée pour un plié en
trois parties c'est juste hallucinant
du coup ce qui est aussi très
intéressant c'est que comme il n'ya pas
d'écran à l'arrière qui va se plier sur
lui-même on imagine que ça va coûter un
peu moins cher à produire et du coup à
commercialiser que le smartphone de
samsung qui lui par contre d'avoir un
seul grand écran à l'intérieur plus un
écran à l'extérieur ce qui du coup
risque vraiment d'augmenter la note et
coûter beaucoup plus cher au
consommateur final
et justement dans le post m me line been
il a parlé à sa communauté en dix ans
pour l'instant on n'a pas besoin du
produit allant fait des propositions
dites nous comment vous voulez qui
s'appelle comment va le baptiser c'est
aussi un très intéressant parce que
stratégiquement ça permet à la
communauté de s'approprier le produit et
puis prendre un peu la température est
de voir les attentes
alors on a des propos ça peut être le
micex a peut être lui
mix f mimix flex ça peut être le millet
face à peut être plein de choses
d'ailleurs dites moi ce que vous en
pensez comment vous voulez que s'appelle
comment voudriez en tout cas que
s'appelle ce smartphone directement en
bas en commentaire en tout cas ce qu'on
voit et ce qui est cool c'est que la
guerre des smartphones pliable n'en est
qu'à son début les marques dégaine de
tous les côtés on n'est qu'en début 2019
pour l'instant de brouillage on à xiaot
me on a cinq secondes attend encore bull
pour une samsung on l'aura dans le
premier semestre 2010 9 ans ça c'est sûr
ça n'est qu'un début
ça va être la nouvelle révolution audrey
les nouveaux usages pour avoir des
écrans toujours plus grand ça va être un
produit qui risque de faire sortir les
tablettes du marché
ou pourquoi pas put être une tablette
professionnelle qui vont peut-être
rester parce que voilà ça soulève pas de
questions c'est vraiment intéressant on
en est strictement qu'au début c'est une
grande révolution qui arrive
croyez moi sont bascule de prix parce
que moi je consacre vraiment hyper
intéressant d'ailleurs je vous invite à
vous abonner parce que d'ici quelques
jours je vais aller au mwc qui est le
gros salon international du mobile à
barcelone
on allait voir un petit peu ce qui se
passe et si ne se sentira pas les
tendances de voir ce qu'il peut se
profiler justement du goûter des
smartphones à écran pliable et à mon
avis on risque d'avoir bonne surprise
alors bien évidemment pour l'instant on
n'a absolument aucune date de sortie le
produit n'est pas aboutie donc aucun
prix mais connaissant la stratégie de
xiaomi avoir pas plus de 5% de marge sur
ses produits
il est franchement sortir un produit à
tarif très agressif et pour justement un
nouveau produit de nouveaux usages ça
peut vraiment mettre un grand coup de
pied dans la fourmilière faire mal aux
autres parce que j'imagine que c'est des
produits qui coûtent très cher on
recherche et développement donc lorsque
vous sortez un produit comme ça derrière
il faut quand même le commercialiser
pour pouvoir rentabiliser et qu'il y ait
de nouveaux clients gagner nous est en
marche et que c'est justement le nouvel
outil qu'est créé à destination d'un
public peut-être plus exigeants à voir
en tout cas ça vraiment passionnant je
vous invite d'ailleurs à me dire ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire est ce que
vous vous voyez l'intérêt d'un
smartphone à écran pliable est ce que
une copie comme celle de chiots mille
peut vous intéresser est-ce que celle de
rougeole peut vous intéresser également
d'ailleurs plus envie d'aller voir la
vidéo je vous lis mis le lien quelque
part en euros ou en bas dans la
description à votre tour de me dire ce
que vous en pensez vous de marquer tout
simple là j'ai mon vol dans
combien de temps
un peu moins de deux heures pour paris
histoire de rentrer un petit peu se
poser avant de reprendre l'avion lundi
matin mais ça c'est une autre histoire
il vous en parle un peu plus tard alors
d'ici là soyez sages prenez soin de vous
et je vous embrasse tchaourou